la semaine dernière on s'y plonger dans
le quotidien de quatre entrepreneurs et
du ministre des finances qui nous ont
fait vivre de l'intérieur la catastrophe
économique du début de pandémie
pour essayer de s'en sortir primé est
quelque chose de brisé le post année
sont prévus
je hais députés qui me texte serait
défendent pour un groupe de pression je
n'ai non kim texte - le groupe de
pression on dit si triste 1 on va
découvrir et qui peu pris les mesures
pour se financer ou est ce pays leur
condition que ces propos
essonne hier
premier en fabrique des séries
on les retrouve cette semaine pour la
suite comment vont-ils s'en sortir
le jem que ça fait pourtant très
vraiment de s'adapter
- chénérailles où je serai très
difficile c'est que il ya une deuxième
bague à louhans
comment vont-ils réussir à produire
alors que la copine fait des ravages
4 0 c'est l'arrière on a dix huit
travailleurs sont affectées de la colle
ici marie maude denis
bienvenue à enquête
si on manque d'argent bah c'est pas trop
même chose certaine on va bosser dessus
nous vante c'est zéro ce qui s'est passé
le gouvernement qu'est ce qui va faire
cesser cette ingestion crise à un matin
et ont besoin de jacques est là mais il
dépasse que pour ses divisions
le grenache perméable les coutures sont
scellés en machine je reçois des coups
on travaille sur l'impasse que sa prime
selon eux il existe au canada même moi
[Musique]
c'est pour ça qu'on joue pendant là nous
on gagne pas qu'on est le meilleur trio
garantie jusqu'en va l'amener à ce qu'on
ferait avec des gens avec qui
s'attardent un contrat pérenne et ayant
demandé des transferts bancaires dans le
compte de dix vie de quelqu'un qu'on
connaît et ça va
'cependant pinto 13 avant des avions
s'est passé palette unique coûte cher
c'est l'avion là lyon le canton va avoir
une divergence ya quinze jours c'est
déprimant pour les 5 millions et ouest
pour eux shanghai 30 ou 40 450 canadien
sur les deux barrages autoroutiers part
ça j'ai passé les états unis auraient
détourné des masques destinés à la
france
on les achetant en argent comptant trois
fois plus cher directement sur le tarmac
de l'aéroport une cargaison de plus d'un
million de masques a été envoyé dans les
hôpitaux sera grande
alors il ya des avions cette semaine
qu'elle louerait maintenant je dois pas
accepter qu'ils chargent et d'avions et
à montgaillard la myopathie
quand on entend l'univers que les cargos
arriver là c'est dramatique c'est fou
c'est important comme dépense perdu ok
avec toi nos élites à bruxelles ok
est-ce que la violence ça m'attriste en
passe partout la confection des
vêtements médicaux - c'est de tout faire
pour
pour toutes les manières créatives de
s'en sortir ou de revoir notre modèle
d'affaires à court terme pour être
capable de gêner petite fille pour être
capable de passer à travers ce qu'ils
vont voir ce qu'ils veulent c'est super
et leurs militants lors auréolé d'un
point
ivre
le piqué sa crise à tous les jours
changement de la marque dans cette pièce
le montre les palin s'y fond de fête
tout comme un système de panier wiam qui
je suis posé les mêmes raisons
c'est qu'on est allés au maximum de ce
type d loppement parce que pour être
rentable faudrait qu'on en fasse deux
fois plus on est pris aussi que des
préjugés restaurant gastronomique m il y
en a certes tout le monde est convaincu
que quand tu fais de la gastronomie est
millionnaire lille vient de manger chez
vous ça leur coûtait 200 pièces sont là
et doit en faire un tabernacle l'argent
quand a décidé de s'occuper de façon
extraordinaire de quelqu'un pendant tout
inquiétés c'est chez vous que le service
est nickel il faut des gens formés que
la bouffe est de qualité et wang tête
engagent les meilleurs que tout ça se
paye ce type ça une valeur c'est ça
qu'il faut que le monde comprenne utile
le ratio de rentabilité
justement du restaurant gastronomique
est minable
ouais mais tu commences tu regardes
voilà mes chefs le jeu peut les mettre
là sur grand écran à tout le monde je
marque alice moi j'ai fait 800 me de
chiffre d'affaires l'année passée qui
chute à - dire que toi
disons qu'on dit moi je veux juste du
banc
moi c'est pour ça qui est venu
finalement la réflexion de on sait pas
trop comment nommer long mais c'est
comme une boutique gastronomique la
commande de numéro un
on utilise l'espace la variable pour la
prise de commande le bus qu'elle avant
de faire un parcours qui faisons en
sorte que les gens se croisent pas non
mais non fait le tour de trouver une
importation de cupides ce que vous
aimeriez voir clémente et 50 dans le
parcours il ya le baron l'utilisent
comme vous êtes fait que les gens
peuvent acheter du vin d'importation et
moi j'ai une cave j'ai pas loin de cent
mille d'un vent par l'autisme que ça
sorte aussi là un moment donné c'est une
façon de le faire ici shooter 2 mois et
on sait que c'est fait on donne un
chauffeur de métaux la raison style ctk
le but c'est d'aller chercher finalement
une rentabilité supplémentaire avec soi
puis d'aller toucher un petit peu plus
de demandes de la région parce que le
tourisme
on s'en doute sans oublier pas
[Musique]
quand on a commencé notre rencontre au
tout tout tout début la première une des
premières choses que vous nous aviez dit
c'est moi le moment qui compte c'est le
début juin parce que les récoltes
comment ils font que j'ai tous mes
travailleurs
alors est-ce que vous avez tout votre
travail en ce sens où je posais les
fesses qu'en aucun cas travailleurs de
rentrer sur 186 et on est toujours au
même endroit avant le 14 juin
bon on peut pas liés par une semaine
avec avec d'autres travailleurs mais sur
une plus longue période
c'est sûr qu'à partir du 15 juin 25 juin
bhl ne s'est pas d'appli mètres limite
après sou après sou c'est la catastrophe
il ya pour personnes qui pensaient qu'on
allait vivre une crise comme ça c'est
extrêmement difficile
la grande différence pour moi le point
de vue personnel c'est le niveau de
stress je pense de savoir que les
entreprises ont besoin de nous de savoir
que les individus sont en difficulté
lorsqu'on faisait des consultations au
sein le dff
en fin de semaine dernière sur les trois
jours de maladie m'a demandé si j'avais
une commotion cérébrale
je m'étais cogner les charmants puis ma
fille a dit premièrement t'as pas une
convention 2e mandat peut-être su store
pour un peu ça ira mieux
[Musique]
il ya dit cool aussi c'est sûr que le
stress
il ya vraiment un prix à payer
c'est difficile quais de seine on
travaille depuis le 4 janvier à tous les
jours je pense que dans trois ans dans
cinq ans on va se rendre compte qu'il y
avait des coûts sociaux
rattaché assauts de la crise à augmenter
le niveau de tension après la pause
une éclosion à la ferme et la santé
publique qui tarde à intervenir
moi je peux t il sont absolument pour
préparer pour ce rituel de vie
[Musique]
c'est sûr que des compliments ne
porterait plus triste c'est qu'on klein
ouais je me vois comme une entreprise
qui était harris nice palmer à ce qu'on
le dit gens qui habitent beaucoup parlé
d'un logement
il a mis au point par les deux certaine
façon vous allez faire un rappel à
l'ordre avec ça c'est sûr que ceux
supportant des rires c'est certain
[Musique]
comment ça tu es comme discuter comme
tel celui d'été de québec a besoin de
certaines libertés
c'est la raison pourquoi je me suis à
lui adresser un peu pas je sentais que
le confinement terre propriétaire ou
sérieux qui jeunes qui traînent depuis
mai sur un vrai raison d'avoir des
craintes
qu'est ce que j'anticipe et harry préval
mais on a dix travailleurs
guatémaltèques confirmé qu'ils ont la
cote
présentement ça a commencé jeudi dernier
qui ont eu leur premier corps sur les 39
personnes qui étaient mis en quarantaine
ont été testés on veut s'assurer de
gérer comme fo on tente de trouver un et
fermière pour nous aider afin de vous
contrôler est important et ce nouveau
contexte où tout le monde vit en
proximité
oui se trouve important en espèces est
ainsi fier
c'est quoi la gco aussi
mercredi 10 juin ce soir à manches l
éclosion du coc vite dans une ferme de
montérégie
une première entreprises agricoles
québécoises qui emploient des
travailleurs étrangers durement touchée
par la coved 19
le producteur maraîcher qui a lui même
dû mettre en place des mesures
exceptionnelles estime que la santé
publique du québec n'est pas prête pour
ce genre de situation en ces veilles des
rixes 30 secondes gagnées les fermes
pouvait devenir des zones rouges et des
foyers de contamination
moi je peux te faisaient ils sont
absolument beaupré paix pour tuer mais
on le vit à sète on note une cazaux qui
rougissait aléria nous ce qu'on retrouve
environ dos travailleurs sont dans cette
cadeaux dans une autre qui va là bas
nous on ne retrouve ici travaillent avec
son look on a dix huit travailleurs sont
affectés giacobbi qu'est-ce que vendredi
je voulais c'est que nullité de la santé
viennent chez nous
notre souhait sincère testé donne
beaucoup de réticences à laisser les
jeunes je pensais que c'était les noirs
et ça ne sais pas
mais n'ont pas tenté cinq ans dont des
dispositions pour septembre
ces personnes bio qui est apposée à
l'aube et q combien d'un positive avec
les autres projets quatre jours
irréaliste vaut actuellement la vitesse
que sa cause pour bâtir les termes qu'on
peut créer une voie c'est le parti unité
tout ce que 300 personnes qui veulent
que tu répondre physiquement ils pas
capables et semaines à la suite de nos
questions la direction de la santé
publique nous a indiqué en fin de
journée que demain elle enverra une
unité mobile sur place pour tester
certains des travailleurs
selon lui ils vont de ces fameuses
examen de conscience en mai d'un web
tout et on est gros et orthez d'un
crochet puis que vous j'ai amélioré agit
il ya pas un vaisseau de ce fait tout
dit en leur promettant juste question
depuis six jours c'est ce qu'on veut on
justifie parfois vers manière parfois
par écrit en voyant les rapports des
clubs qu'est ce qu'on fait
non là on est à dans la pire situation
possible convient d'espérer une valse
etc si on a passé nous liquidity c'est
le mot de joker pour de popstars en est
donc là si je comprends bien vous n'avez
même plus démarche de tri 10 00 devenait
dangereux parce que nous le kit était
riche et photos dans mon téléphone
9h25 le camion reculer là pour nous
amener les jackets et puis là je
regardais mon directeur d'entrepôts là
je pense qu'on vient de prendre un bon
bouillon et vous donne pas de commande
on a 26 palette d'effets rouge et je
sais pas qu'est ce qu'on va faire avec
ça avez vous une part oui pas ces
liquidités sont afin qu'on n'a pas de
commande
on faisait jouer encore un peu
il est déjà capital et elle recontacte
et son contact qui nous avait pas donné
à camara
nos demandes et les villes où est-ce que
l'exacte sont en ce moment sont ici sont
dans l'entrepôt il ne croyait pas
sont entendues sur le prix et de quotas
que dis je vous envoie robin transporte
aussi parce qu'il n'y avait pas de
jaquette pour passer la fin de semaine
[Musique]
quand on a su que le gouvernement
prenait nos jokers finalement coach
estime tout le monde est fou deuxième
nos mômes en entrepôt est imparti moulin
par ce chant taux de livret a produit et
tu logistique sont descendus pour nous
aider à charger de camions de rebelles
contre
[Musique]
le québec a fermé approximativement 40%
de son économie au mois d'avril pour
contrôler la pandémie et lomé ont des
confine progressivement le travail
d'étude en passant une bonne nouvelle
pour vous
heureuse tant pis et la maison des
contes film doucement et si seulement
qu'en juin que normalement on devrait
avoir repris peu pourcentage est porteur
l'activité
cette semaine voit le premier ministre
on commence à discuter de ce qu'on va
faire à l'énoncé complément à vos clips
présentent la situation je tends moyen
terme mois un scénario qui serait très
difficile c'est que je sois obligé on ya
une deuxième vague à l'automne on
regarde sans tain on ne le deuxième
vague à l'otan dont reconfirme après une
accalmie s'était ce sport bon et ce qui
est important c'est que dans les
scénarios très difficile qu'on perd le
contrôle
[Musique]
je suis ok
à midi à 5h événements puis elle a émis
un délit médias et l ' on s'entend que
c'était principalement les gens de la
communauté le soleil
[Musique]
je pense que tout le monde est venu
juste me dire le qui tenait à moi de moi
ma question c'est qui s'occupe de lui et
là j'ai eu ma réponse
ça devait être un peu grise en de revoir
les gens g20 y avoir envie de des
produits que quelque chose s'est pas
j'ai vraiment failli pleurer de joie le
cje quelques uns des moyens annoncés
dont 20 grandi au sous sol
c'est un petit peu d'être ce qu'on a
besoin le silence et de sentir que tu es
supporter par la communauté c'est
principalement sur ces même si on
transformait le restaurant genre de
petit marché de l'autonomie alimentaire
ça sera pas suffisant là pour qu'on
puisse s'en sortir
il nous faut quelque chose qui va être
un petit peu un petit peu à l'abri des
tempêtes puis je pense que la cantine
fait vraiment partie de la culture
québécoise mais quand il va faire le lit
des câbles ils sont rentables ces gens
là pourquoi parce que il s'occupa toit
pendant trois ans il s'occupe de tout
parmi mes notes après il ya un gars
nommé note parce que tout un pays attend
ici à l'église
c'est centre des loisirs
le fait d'être à côté ça nous oblige pas
à acheter des camions réfrigérés
il ya à peu près 40 de décret sur ce que
je veux installer pour rien le t6
l'urbanisme a dit oui à ce projet leur
aux autres leur groupe en blanc que
celles ci on te permet à toi vote
installé leur va falloir qu'on puisse
permettre ça adopté moi je leur disais
j'ai mon restaurant ici le lieu physique
c'est du resto existe c'est logique que
j'aie un sous produit de mon restaurant
tu es à côté de mon restaurant
on va prendre les mesures la table sans
nuage on aurait juste et les cils
j'aimerais inventé mais font l'ouverture
le faut qu' il ya des choses qui sont
plus possibles parce que dans les
situations financières dans lesquelles
on est faut trouver le moyen de faire de
la business simplifier l'urbanisme de la
ville pour essayer de faire un espèce de
fermi temporaire on veut que vous vous
êtes supplicié et on veut pas être
obligé d'investir 400 villes pour
membres des patates et le projet que
j'ai présenté ses quarante mille îles
c'est le coût total du projet nous
moi je le voyais la satim que tu peux
aussi prendre des commandes de bleu puis
les portes de garage des socialistes
pour tech vidéo est bon et ouvrir la
saint jean saint jean baptiste
da 3 400 m ouais ouais
oui en attendant on va commander départ
[Musique]
après la pause un ministre des finances
qui marche sur des oeufs situation des
finances publiques de seuils
spécifiquement coutume en crise
après des semaines de confinement et de
déconfinement c'est l'heure de vérité
pour le ministre des finances c'est le
moment de dire aux québécois quel sera
l'impact économique de cette pandémie
vous allez voir qu'il y en aura pas de
facile on aura une meilleure idée de
l'impact financier de la crise au québec
ce matin le ministre des finances eric
girard va déposer un énoncé budgétaire
complémentaire à 10h30 ce matin j'ai
pratiqué puis le hayon dire il ya trop
de chez check enlève ses chefs lors des
x moi je connais les chefs d'état je
connais les numéros de pages et les
notes de bas de page la réponse est
simple ans arrivait lui a tout fait un
effort j'essaie d'être le plus
précis possible mon équipe ce matin on
vous savez on fait des drailles ron
envoyé beaucoup de périodes de questions
aussi mulet votre équipe qui nous
rappelle de position des mots comme
annualisé bresso kelly j'en ai pris un
point nominale ou si je pense que le
ministre des finances y ait un rôle de
bié vulgariser l'information
alors c'est important d'être compris
je
quand c'est très stressant parce que
d'abord il ya beaucoup de monde qui ont
travaillé fort les ministères mon
cabinet il ya déjà quelques minutes
comme unis aujourd'hui je représente le
gouvernement a lors d'un salo si moi je
m'en fiche c'est pas grave mais c'est
important de bien faire 15 10 ou publics
feront revenir à l'équilibré budgétaire
en 5 1 je lance passe en l'air comme ça
j'ai déjà indigné mais chiffres
j'en ai déjà pas avec le premier
ministre lui est déjà monté où on allait
avoir des chouettes c'est la fin qui
maillard ont déjà existé la sphère
souvent des choix difficiles à faire
sont dans les ministères
en dehors des deux missions respadd
clairement sa descente éducation alors
bonjour à tous les dépenses pour faire
face à la pandémie des dépenses
budgétaires sont en hausse de 6 points 6
milliards aujourd'hui ce qu'on voulait
faire c'était de donner leurs jeux ce
québécois combien ça coûte et l'a promis
combien ça coûte et les masses combien
ça coûte et lisa supplément par l'it est
ce qui nous amène en déficit
aujourd'hui c'est une reddition comme le
disait roja voici ce que ça a coûté
c'est d'avoir une crise saint quentin il
ya ensuite m crise économique il ya une
situation très du soleil finances
publiques de spécifiquement pour tulle
mot crise qu'avait fait en sorte de ne
pas employer le terme crise ça me
rappelle les années où le gouvernement
couillard ne voulait pas employer le
terme
austérité benz que ce sera pas de
l'austérité je peux vous des gens
choisiront les termes qu'ils veulent
déterminer ce que niveau il ya beaucoup
de préparation associé à sausset long ça
fait du bien car c'est terminé on va
aller tout de suite à eric girard je
voulais annoncé en début d'émission eric
girard ménès des finances bonjour
bonjour il y avait un consensus et
penser il reporte consensus pour le
retour à l'équipe et l'histoire sont
intelligents comprennent bien que c'est
un [ __ ] va devoir être remboursés
dantin et puis que ça va venir en partie
de leur poche est ce que il y a il ya de
l'aide qui s'en vient du gouvernement du
québec nous on impose un premier jeu
avec une aide de 400 millions pour les
sociétés pas comment gérer la crise tout
le monde est d'accord
alors tout le monde est derrière la
création du 17 heures
mais le plan de retour à l'équilibré
tout un débat de société au québec et au
fédéral
avez vous la ressentez quelque sorte
déjà entrain de votre carrière
[Musique]
j'ai vraiment pas l'impression de jouer
ma carrière puis le cyclone impression
continent
tu es sévère récession et que faut
vraiment être concentré pour faire le
mieux compris
[Musique]
l'ouverture et le moral est très bon et
les malheureusement dans l'ensemble de
ce que les gens disent que c'est moi lol
on n'est pas loin du 1er juillet je
connais pas personnes qui l'ont envoyé
sont noyés 2 avril et la connais pas
beaucoup plus mordant venu celui donné
je suis 5 millions dans le tout j'ai
ouvert la caisse enregistreuse encore et
quand je vois le nourrit tout le monde
me dit que je voterai l'important de ce
que je veux c'est de ne pas remplir il
doit vendre mon stock and the city c'est
ingérable
moi ça va être le combat de ma vie les
centres d'achat des centres d'achat tout
ce qu'ils ont lu sa fin c'est de dire on
va rapporter les loyers des revenus les
met en avant deux ans puis ils sont
revenus hier avec une contre proposition
ben qui fait pas la vérité c'est qu'il
fait pas la fin du tout entendu andulo à
payer 50% vivante en loyer c'est juste
pas soutenable c'est juste podium c'est
un plus de surf au pays 3 alors que les
héros revenus mais ça ça fait juste nous
tuer en octobre l'une où tu es
maintenant nos vertes sont bonnes et on
fait un peu bu un peu plus la randonnée
il y en a du viaduc de smarties un bocal
vote front commun en plus exquis fort je
sais pas ils comprennent bord le
détaillant de vêtements rythme on se
place sous la protection des tribunaux
gérald le groupe ados se place à l'abri
de ses créanciers oui à la question
est-ce que triste 1
danger la réponse est non et oui est-ce
que tristan en danger oui est ce que la
plupart des différents sont en danger
oui alors on veut pas régler ça en bon
geek et leurs bons clients
freeport dessins de il dit il ya des
procédures légales professeur tad
va foirer ce placer sa protection la loi
sur les arrangements avec les créanciers
vous permet de mettre fin un bar c'est
la seule chose qui nous reste
au bout des ongles si on n'est pas
capable s'entend on voit d'objets des
rides
vous vous donnez jusqu'à caen avant
d'aborder cette carte là de l'âge la loi
de la protection des créanciers ont
longtemps
[Musique]
finalement il ya comme une ouverture
dans les régions finalement il ya
beaucoup de tours et ce même si une
région qui était déjà beaucoup visité le
mont sion fin
[Musique]
au niveau du volume je fais deux fois
plus de volume 6 ans lille de patates
sizing de mayonnaise c'est nous en
format gastronomique n'a jamais fait ses
ses deux chaudières fils oui non si 4,70
toi ben j'ai trop pressé puisqu'au
partout fait je me dis rien mais pareil
je fais quand même comme ailleurs il ya
beaucoup de gens sont mamans mais
lorsque tu vas rester comme ça est ce
que tu voir par son restaurant est ce
que mais moi je fais jouer moi je survis
[Musique]
c'est pas quelque chose que j'avais
prévu que ce restaurant le deviendra si
on va un petit peu été comme une fenêtre
sur l'évolution de la cuisine au québec
c'est là où j'ai mon deuil c'est la
passion de départ est vraiment aidé à
mener la cuisine ailleurs au québec
je renonce un peu à la représentation de
la gastronomie aussi à l'étranger et à
l'international parce que ça va pas
révolutionner la cuisine à l'étranger
avec une quantité ça c'est vraiment pour
les gens d'ici
[Musique]
il ya quelque chose d'intéressant aussi
dans cette formule là ça serait beaucoup
plus facile pour moi de délégués de
standardiser à quelques parties de faire
des bébés
les recettes propres plus simple
toujours avec des produits de bonne
qualité mais mais oui effectivement
c'est moins stressant c'est moins
stressant
fafard et pas quand on regarde année
après la pause
triste un frappe un mur
[Musique]
c'est l'observatoire
non
[Musique]
je passe à l'achat
on voulait pas que ça soit notre premier
recours mais il fallait quand même que
ça soit à ce parti de nos stratégies
dans l'au delà
c'est sûr ce n'est pas le mien moi je
suis à lui que nicky loh qui en mourront
donc non non on n'est point comme
d'exception
deux hivers qu'on laisse
[Musique]
je me nourris à l'épicier de viol
c'est le ternois
mais qu'est ce qui va se passer à
l'écrit en interne il me dit c'est mon
patelin et tout le monde est bon mais
énorme de tende
on est un peu une source de fierté
[Musique]
hulot
on va vers une terre
[Musique]
alors on a organisé la réunion
aujourd'hui parce qu'on vit et prendre
une décision très importante qui on
voulait que vous soyez les premiers à le
savoir
ce soir vous allez probablement voir
dans les nouvelles dans les médias des
nouvelles qui ressemble pour des titres
qui ressemble à ce qu'on a vu pour des
aldudes reitman sous différents canaux
base de roach et de la période la
journée a rappelé ce matin c'est romain
tecteo staff
tu parles de business comme si elle va
bien quand c'est que à tout hasard tous
vos yeux que lâcher le morceau tarde
d'en finir aixois su surfer les centres
d'achats qui nous coûte 9 fortune on a
essayé de faire comprendre avec le bon
vin ça ne marche pour tout le monde le
dit j'ai fait ma tête de cochon des 10,3
et joie et convaincre ben c'est un flop
vous êtes soulagé que cela ne soit pas
soulagé je sais pas on n'est plus dans
la phase d'acceptation que c'est la
meilleure chose à faire c'est la
meilleure décision à prendre pour dix
ans pour nous employer pour nos clients
pour l'entreprise
ça a pris du temps à arriver à cette
conclusion là c'est dans cette phase là
dans cet état d'esprit de
[Musique]
c'est au tour de la chaîne de boutiques
tristan de demander la protection des
tribunaux pour éviter la faillite
il va voler les prochaines heures la
couverture médiatique s'agit - pourquoi
est ce que vous craignez ce que j'aime
pas du nom le nom de la loi
dès qu'il ya faillite et insolvabilité
dans le nom
mais je pense que les clients et par
conçoit pas l'eau confère une décision
logique et rationnel que le g hélas
ionel on a une culture d'entrepreneurs
qui vient de la campagne de l'arbre des
impayés nous dit on fait attention nous
faisons aux prétentions du client alors
demain matin quand vous allez arriver
mais il vient de réceptionner sa
déception
il va avoir dit kevin en cave est fière
de même atteint jumelles gagne ça m a
fait ce qu'on fait de mieux
car selon sécher les larmes là il faut
se forcer pour faire les plus beaux
vêtements qui possible son album stock
envoie sans succès la situation est
critique
ces plaques était de 15 qu'on a mis en
place ces mesures là l'action l'est dans
la cellule de crise de sa vie non les
dans la deuxième vague six essais le
premier binaisse daruda c'est christiane
tibie y en a car mamadou riblet cette
cellule santé lancée eux qui ont la
pression
entre stress dans les hôpitaux blessés
hcb
merci beaucoup bien qu on a des
nouvelles existants sur les vaccins tous
sauf les six prochains mois vont être
difficiles on est dans la deuxième vague
le virus est toujours présent ya
seulement 5% de l'économie qui fermait
présentement versus 40 pour ça dans la
première vague puis ces gens l'os qui
vivent c'est extrêmement difficile mais
fallait qu'on fasse quelque chose tu
content pour le faire deschamps lui
souhaite beaucoup de résilience bien
qu'ici prochains mois sont très
difficiles devant nous le voile au
printemps prochain
beaucoup des sports
[Musique]
chanter ses fans zone
non seulement on a sauvé là on a acheté
les compléments machin légumes devront
rembourser mon cher petit logiquement on
n'est pas positif le on avait emprunté
aussi un autre 50 milles sur notre
maison que qu'on peut rembourser
partiellement mais oui c'est positif les
litchis
métier
[Musique]
les deux semaines la construction les
deux dernières de juillet moi j'ai des
cuisiniers qui vomissait tellement il
était lourd que l'on travaillé seize ans
par jour
on était vraiment vraiment lumière qu'on
n'aurait pas pu tenir plus longtemps que
ça a duré quatre semaines d'achalandage
juste complètement surréel
on a annoncé sur le facebook quand
finalement ce que quand réouvrir le
restaurant gastronomique l'année
prochaine ok à temps peut alors leur
marque comme ça donc non seulement tu
veux vu ouvrir tard quand il maîtrise
aussi réouvrir raison je veux pas bah
oui ouvrir le restaurant bail
pourquoi mais bien parce que je m'ennuie
j'ai besoin de la gastronomie pour
continuer à moi évoluer mais est tout ce
que tu nous as dit faisons tous les
derniers mois le fait que cette 20e
clients qu'il paya le fait que ce soit
convivial parce qu'il faudrait sans
terre amendes france composer avec ça le
30e client est payant avec le nombre
d'employés que j'ai l'air si je garde la
cantine je peux garder toutes mes
employés puis réduire le nombre
d'employés
on mérite de soins secoué une fois de
temps en temps il faut accepter c'est
ces périodes eu trop de lois qui
permettent à l'humanité de ce ne sera
soir de se redéfinir et de se
reconstruire
[Musique]
j ans hier on a fait plus avec moins
le plus gros ajouté j'aimerais sens du
bit est le seul cent croient qu'il
savait comment affronter lille gros
enjeu l'on dit dont les véhicules des
gros problèmes on disait évidemment
souhaité faut que ça devienne y en a en
temps car il ya un office qui arrivait
guatémaltèque qui laisse croire qu'il ny
avait pas quijano qui en aucun cas alors
à lyon et notre personnel ou s'il ya un
enjeu de s'adapter on voit que les
appels via tous les 26 travail a qui
sont à livrer le point ils sont tout à
l'hôtel depuis un mois et demi après on
fait des tests systématiques lors de
l'arrivée en bio deux semaines ou trois
semaines les autorités de la santé des
jeunes aient été pistés sur castres qui
a redit ballons propres face au jeu vous
avez les phocéens et les travailleurs
que je sois moi je crois que c'est
exactement ce ne serait pas si les
dirigeants souhaiteraient petit saut
mais amateur à m'établir ressources
humaines pointeur de la face au palais
comme moi
ça me repose et qu'on sait pas où et
qu'il faut qu'on fasse mais faut c'est à
moi et ressources humaines pour être
capable y déployer le bébé qui est un
des sujets dans la chambre a lu tous les
grands problèmes du monde a voté mardi
une dilution instantanée des tracts dans
les centres commerciaux
suite à la longue des ombres ça a été
toujours l'emmène à des trafics
à -65 moins 60 sur l'année passée la
bonne chose qu'on allait d'une passe
on a arrêté de veine là dans le faire à
tout prix même en perte est en fait
qu'ils vont me dis si le black friday
webdocu descente il va emmener noël ils
vont pas nous fermerons
on avait été jusqu'à la fin on a été
planté l2 et l'on arrive à une période
où on doit décider c'est quoi la
prochaine étape pour pour notre musée
vous dirai pas plus car il n'y a pas une
mode comme ça et nous on a continué à
produire en commun leurs idées quand l
heure le stock et puis y'a pas de cadres
qui se donne quelques indices
ils pensent que vous constatez entre je
t'aimais de la misère a critiqué en ce
moment le garder les yeux bleus et aux
lions de paniers bleus bien au delà mais
quand la jaked voilà tu es car nous
sommes chaque fois ici dont elles ont
besoin d'un million japon n'est pas seul
libyan à bas salaires - chien méchant un
réseau qui ont payé le gros prix mana
génération d'affaires l'homme alors des
15 milliards
il ya d'abord la cette génération-là
d'acquis dans livres d'art mama c'est le
document pays de l'acolyte de 2013
[Musique]
c'est comme ça que se terminent les
missions pour ce soir au nom de toute
l'équipe merci beaucoup d'avoir été là
et je vous souhaite de très joyeuses
fêtes je vous donne rendez vous le 14
janvier pour d'autres enquêtes
[Musique]